things which attracts me forbidden in
the green because it's the greenest city
in Europe and also I love the Eastside
of Bailey and it's changing every day
and I love it
that's why dragoon opened his Moroccan
restaurant the casbah in the mitad
district of former East Berlin the area
is also called fund our force not many
old buildings here are over a century
old most buildings are listed the
district is also known for its many art
galleries Larissa who has been serving
dishes from his Moroccan homeland at
casbah since 2003 besides good food he
offers an insight into Moroccan culture
I live here now I am part of here alia
good kids here and I want my country to
have part in Deutschland in Germany
especially in building many people come
to me and they go to Morocco only of
these things of this decor like it's
like my country exists in Germany
Driss ago decorated his restaurant like
a Moroccan salon where people meet to
drink tea and dine he had the
furnishings built in his home town of
fists according to his own design
[Music]
in Morocco people generally eat with
their hands after they've cleaned him
with rosewater a guru has made this a
small ritual for his guests when I'm
cooking I try to test if every second
and I cook it from my heart it's like I
cook it for home I don't cut the corners
that's the recipe they are famous in my
city in Fez Moroccan cuisine often
combines sweet and spicy ingredients
lamb is the most popular type of meat in
Morocco
preparing the meals is painstaking and
time-consuming to get the right
consistency and unique taste the meat is
first marinated and then cooked slowly
at a low temperature
[Music]
the meals are flavored with rose or
orange water and honey a tagine is a
typical feature in a Moroccan kitchen
it's the name of the meal and the pot in
it dishes are prepared gently and with
great care this is very costly that's
usually people they don't do it every
day and yeah it takes a long time so it
was only when he had some good friend of
my pant coming home Trisha good was born
in Fez Morocco is third largest city in
1962 at the age of 17 he went to Paris
to study to become a structural engineer
afterwards he moved to London and
because he was short of money he worked
as a dishwasher and waiter after he met
his German wife Ingrid they decided to
move to Berlin in 2002 and opened their
own restaurant all my friend he didn't
like it he said to me you're crazy
because I give notice to my job I put my
flat him say I just came here and they
don't speak German and how I'm going to
earn my living and he told me that it
would be hard but I like because this
kind of life is not born in life and I
love it
the heart of every Moroccan house is the
riad or inner courtyard it's a small
oasis of tranquility in the busy city
the casbah as a riad to Andres opens it
for guests in the summer new-type
Nottingham blah blah blah carful blessed
who wants a beer Malcolm Ziad are within
the cochlea of Hara
[Music]